as investigators look over videos from
last week's assault on the capitol
they are learning that some rioters used
military style
tactics those rioters appeared to use
methods like hand signals to communicate
suggesting they had military training
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge has been looking into
this and joins us from washington
catherine what do we learn well anthony
good morning a law enforcement official
confirms to cbs
news that the identification of riders
who use military style tactics
is a tier one priority for the u.s
attorney's sedition task force here in
washington
with federal investigators sifting
through more than a hundred and thirty
thousand digital media tips
some videos stand out i ran this by
probably three or four
senior swat guys and we all kind of
agreed
some kind of training scott sweeto is a
former
fbi atf explosives expert who
investigated
the 1995 oklahoma city and 1996
centennial olympic park bombings you
have all these people that are facing
away from the capital
they're singing
and then you have this group that is
moving quickly
and with a purpose up the steps of the
capital that's
pretty scary when you look at
what those people are doing officials
say former or current military and law
enforcement
have already been arrested for
participating in last week's attack
the pentagon says jacob fracker one of
two
off-duty virginia cops arrested for
breaking into the capitol
is a corporal in the virginia national
guard and the army
is still trying to determine the current
status of thomas robertson
who apparently served at different times
both for the national guard and reserves
cbs news has learned videos like this
drew immediate scrutiny
because they mirror tactics used by law
enforcement and the military
to navigate hostile or unknown
environments
what are small unit tactics you know
small unit tactics are
ways that uh military can blanket and
and and and communicate and try to get
to a
primary target that they have
frank saluffo is a former senior
homeland security official
this isn't out of a basement this isn't
playing a whole lot of video games this
is something that there was some
training here there's no question
once the capitol was breached cbs news
has learned
a d.c police officer witnessed some
rioters using
military-style hand signals to
communicate it would
not be unusual for people to come up
with physical signals such as tapping
them
pulling on them something that would
work in a crowd where you had a lot of
noise and a lot of chaos
why is the identification of individuals
like this
so important to the investigation at the
end of the day
a small number of sophisticated actors
can
can do a whole lot of harm
this is shaping up to be one of the
biggest cases in u.s history that relies
so heavily on videotape
evidence in addition to social media cbs
news has learned that federal
investigators
are pouring through thousands of hours
of security camera video
from the supreme court the library of
congress and the capitol itself
as well as police body cam video tony
can't get through it fast enough
catherine thank you very much